during this war thousands of children
have disappeared from Ukraine
taken by the Russians
this is the extraordinary story of 15
orphans who escaped their clutches and a
look at the fate of the many others who
haven't been so lucky
in a safe place in the Georgian capital
of Tbilisi
the ordeal is now over for these
Ukrainian orphans it lasted five months
a harrowing Journey that took them a
thousand miles before they made it to
Freedom
[Applause]
[Music]
thanks to a remarkable woman
they're the director of their orphanage
when Russian forces seize the area
we know from CCTV footage taken in
another orphanage how the Russian
military has searched for children in
this war
three weeks after it began they turned
up at Natalia's orphanage too menacing
men in uniform with guns seeking out her
children
videos
[Music]
she begged the Russians to let her take
her children to Ukrainian Health
territory is
when the war started Natalia's special
school in the village of Nova patrivica
in southern Ukraine had a hundred
children she managed to send 85 of them
to relatives before Russian forces moved
in and occupied the area four months
later Russian soldiers came to take the
15 children left in her care
um
Russian State TV filmed the day for
propaganda purposes their footage shows
the children being loaded onto buses but
not what the children say happened
before that that they pleaded with the
military not to take them and Russian
soldiers fired their guns to make the
move fourteen-year-old Dasha describes
those chilling moments
um
foreign
they say they were moved against their
will at gunpoint
a clear violation of the laws of war
Natalia's nightmare was deepening
manipulations
Natalia and her 15 orphans were moved
150 miles deeper Behind Enemy Lines to
another orphanage in the village of
stephanievka
at first it seemed little to worry about
the summer passed and the war seems
distant
but in October the Russians were back to
move them again this time into occupied
Crimea
is
it
foreign
Russia was withdrawing from the area
retreating across the danipra river and
taking civilians and children with them
for the orphans it was terrifying
um
Trail
his fears were well founded the children
were on the way to Russia from
stephanievka and into Russian occupied
Crimea ending up at the city of jankoy
the next day from there the Russians
transported them through Crimea that
across the Kurt Strait taking them over
the border and into Russia Natalia did
what she could to reassure the children
telling them whatever happened they
wouldn't be forgotten
you see
below
back
they were heading for a network of
institutions in regions that spread
across Russia and Russian occupied
Crimea where Ukrainian children have
reportedly been sent from their Homeland
even though it's a war crime to take
them to a foreign country
some of them are more than 6 000 miles
away and Russia's Far East Sky News has
confirmed these institutions have taken
in Ukrainian children some are
orphanages some are summer camps and
some are boarding schools
we know Ukrainian teenagers were at this
summer camp in chechnya Russia says with
the consent of their parents as its
promotional videos show military-style
training is a key activity children are
taught to handle and fire weapons
at another camp south of Moscow where
Ukrainian teenagers have been sent
children are taught that Ukraine is part
of Russia
in an orphanage a thousand miles into
Russia children draw pictures showing
the protection of the motherland and
near Saint Petersburg the artwork of
more young children in an exhibit
entitled the battle power of Russia
and there are many more locations across
the country where Ukrainian children
have reportedly been sent into a system
that appears to indoctrinate young
people in the authoritarian ideology of
putanist Russia
to avoid exploitation and propaganda
we've obscured faces and changed names
but the stories of four children can
paint a picture of the experiences of
many
there's 12 year old Elena who suffers
from a severe physical condition and
also has learning difficulties she's
seen here smiling in a photo taken in
her Ukrainian orphanage and then
pictured again after Russians had moved
her looking withdrawn with a shaved head
Katarina also not her real name as a
Ukrainian teenager sent 600 miles into
Russia she said she wants to go home to
Donetsk
social media shows a boy from Ukraine in
the same institution filmed making a
speech saying faith and Glory are with
Russia forever Victory is close
Ivan is another young child from
daniette's consent to an institution
hundreds of miles into Russia he appears
in a Russian news report here another
propaganda film in their information War
Jim
the patient regime has exploited
Ukrainian children in events overseen by
the president himself
[Music]
these children from the city of
mariupole destroyed by Russia paraded in
a stadium in Moscow
the Russians claimed they're saving
children from a war zone an acting for
humanitarian reasons
but that hasn't saved both Vladimir
Putin and his children's rights
commissioner Maria lover Bulova from
being indicted for the war crime of
deporting children by the international
criminal court
even if she rejects the allegations
against her
besides
um foreign
[Music]
in these photos published by the Russian
government Maria lavova belova has seen
welcoming children from Ukraine
transported two and a half thousand
miles to its East waiting Russian
families are ready to receive the
children
war crimes investigators say Russia's
trafficking of children adds up to
genocide and its claims do not stand
scrutiny
we handed the evidence we've collected
to kiev-based British lawyer and
international criminal rights
investigator Wayne jordash he says it
helps build the case that Russia is
engaged in genocide they want the
children to accept Russia as their
motherland I think it goes to the
overall criminal plan which is to
extinguish extinguish Ukrainian identity
so we're talking about cultural genocide
and we're also talking about physical
genocide
and yet the Russians say and they're
very open about this they say what
they're doing is saving children from
war
if this was about welfare then the
Russians Administration would contact
the icrc would contact the UN would
contact a range of international ngos
and help to reunite those children with
their parents or their Guardians
this is
unlike thousands of others are 15
orphans Journey ended in Escape From
Russia from a camp in a Napa they
crossed the border and reached the
Georgian Capital Tbilisi in November a
lucky few fighting Sanctuary after
months caught up in Russia's brutal war
and occupation
they showed us the root of their
extraordinary Odyssey throughout Natalia
had been in touch with International
volunteers waiting for them worried
they're about to be taken deeper into
Russia
they were three days away from being
dispersed which is they put the kids on
the train the trains are eastbound they
go all the way to the Far East of Russia
so eight days on a train and at the
stops people who want a child or if a
village has been told you will send
somebody to get one the kids are handed
out at the station and the people told
us now your child go register them at
the town office
the children remember the moment they
left Russia and the relief they felt as
they reached safety
is
foreign
to their Homeland
their deliverance from Russia only
happen through the extraordinary courage
and determination of Natalia
who can look back now knowing she's kept
her word to the children and led them to
safety
representations
foreign